und in KF ist unsere Korrespondentin
Katrin Eigendorf guten Tag wir erleben
Sie gerade die Lage in Kiew
ja die Lage war heute morgen noch mal
ziemlich angespannt es hat über mehrere
Stunden raketen-alarm gegeben das heißt
alle Geschäfte hier waren zu schulen
sind geschlossen Kindergärten sind
geschlossen der Bürgermeister von Kiew
hat die Bürger aufgefordert nach
Möglichkeit nicht draußen herumzulaufen
es wurde jetzt gerade erst Entwarnung
gegeben aber natürlich rechnet man hier
in der Hauptstadt jederzeit damit dass
es hier weitere Raketenangriffe geben
könnte die Lage ist also nach wie vor
eigentlich ziemlich unklar denn es sieht
ja so aus dass Russland weiter überall
in der Ukraine vor allem kritische
Infrastruktur
angreift das ist hier in der Hauptstadt
ein großes Problem denn hier ist
teilweise die
Elektrizitätsversorgung eingeschränkt
man hat mittlerweile in bestimmten
Stadtteilen nur für bestimmte Uhrzeiten
die Möglichkeit noch Strom zu haben das
ist ein Problem und was für die Ukraine
insgesamt ein Problem ist natürlich je
mehr kritische Infrastruktur also sowohl
Elektrizitätswerke als auch
Stromversorger und auch
Energieunternehmen die im Prinzip ja für
die Wärmeversorgung zuständig sind hier
getroffen werden desto problematischer
wird es hier für die Bevölkerung denn es
steht ja auch der Winter hier bevor die
G7-Staaten die beraten heute noch mal
über die ganz aktuelle Situation der
ukrainische Präsident selenski wird
zugeschaltet welche Erwartungen hat er
jetzt an die G7
also silensky wird sicherlich noch
einmal ganz klar die Erwartung äußern
und Druck machen dass hier jetzt
möglichst schnell Technologie
Waffentechnologie geliefert wird und
zwar auf der einen Seite als Konsequenz
dieser Luftangriffe das einfach die
Luftabwehr noch mal deutlich verstärkt
wird und dass der Westen da mehr
Unterstützung zu sich hat die USA haben
sicher da bereits dazu geäußert dass sie
das tun werden aber die Ukrainer Streben
natürlich an dass die Luftabwehr hier
deutlich im ganzen Land verbessert
werden muss denn das war eine
Schwachstelle die gestern dazu geführt
hat dass eben Städte wie Kiew dann doch
von so vielen Raketen getroffen wurden
die hier mitten ins Zentrum zielten ein
weiterer Punkt ist aber natürlich auch
die Situation am Boden also silensky
will auch Bodentruppen verstärken denn
das ist ja eigentlich das wichtigste
Ziel für die Ukrainer abgesehen von der
Luftabwehr dass sie dafür sorgen wollen
dass alle besetzten Gebiete hier wieder
befreit werden davon ist man noch weit
entfernt und dafür braucht selensky
braucht die Ukraine entsprechende Waffen
aus dem Westen live aus KF Einschätzung
von Katrin Eigendorf vielen Dank